Adam Driver's performance as Kylo Ren is easily
one of the best parts of the Star Wars sequels
— and ever since his debut in The Force
Awakens, the character has stood firm as one
of the franchise's most beloved villains.
But just how did Driver prepare himself for
the part?
In the wake of 9/11, a 17-year-old Adam Driver
postponed his acting dreams in order to join
the Marines.
Prior to this, the actor had tried and failed
to get into the Juilliard performance school.
During a TED Talk he gave in 2015, Driver
elaborated on his decision to abandon the
arts and join the armed forces.
"I joined the Marine Corps and I loved it,
I loved being a Marine.
It’s one of the things I’m most proud
of having done in my life."
Driver's career in the Marines was cut short
when he was medically discharged.
Luckily, however, he reapplied to Juilliard
soon after — and this time, he got in.
Many years later, Driver used his military
experience to drive Kylo Ren's physicality.
"How he responds to things is probably a bit
physically quicker than most, because he’s,
you know, it’s on edge, they’re at war."
But that's not the only useful experience
Driver gained from the Marines.
"My experience from the military was more
in the relationships, actually, that I formed.
And that kind of camaraderie and like, the
work ethic and working as a… as a team."
The actor has also explained how a military
environment can be similar to life on a movie
set.
"There's somebody in charge who knows what
they’re doing, the director and when they
know what they’re doing, what you’re doing
feels kind of exciting and important and when
they don’t, it feels like a waste of time."
One thing that many people assume about Adam
Driver is that he can be a pretty intense
guy on-set.
And while some of his Star Wars co-stars are
known for enjoying a laugh or two on set,
Driver has garnered a reputation for being
almost as brooding as Kylo Ren himself.
In an interview with Radio 1, Driver's co-star
John Boyega explained:
"I think when he's on set as Kylo Ren, the
Dark Side of the Force likes to capture him
sometimes."
Speaking about their time filming The Last
Jedi, Star Wars veteran Mark Hamill told Vanity
Fair:
"He’s very moody and intense.
I remember saying to Adam, ‘I don’t know
how you work, or your technique.'
[...] All I’m suggesting is, if you’d
like, maybe we could go to lunch, we could
get together and hang out.”
But Driver insists this wasn't part of his
process — he just likes to stay in the zone
between takes.
The actor told Vulture:
"I like to stay focused on set, but it's not
because I have a process that I'm imposing
on everybody else.
Sometimes you have to be more focused in between
scenes because [...] it's pure comedy in between
takes."
One way Driver did that was by sometimes staying
in character as Ren after the cameras stopped
rolling — even though he's not usually a
method actor.
The fact is that Kylo Ren is a complex and
serious character, so, for his scenes, jokes
with Driver's castmates had to come second
to his performance.
Driver's co-star Domhnall Gleeson later explained:
"There's enough going on already without adding
in knock-knock jokes.
[…] Depending on the day, Adam is hilarious,
but he's always good."
Starring in a franchise as huge and beloved
as Star Wars is always going to come with
an overwhelming amount of pressure.
When Driver first began work on 2015's The
Force Awakens, he found that dealing with
that pressure was a matter of simply not thinking
about it.
"I think with the first one, it was more terror.
Or denying that, you know, ‘Oh look, there’s
the Millennium Falcon.’
You’re like, OK, put it out of your mind
and focus on the story."
In a different interview, Driver admitted
that it wasn't just the history of the franchise
that added pressure to his performance, but
also the sheer scale of the project.
He said that, by the time he had begun filming
on The Last Jedi:
"The level of terror, I think, was different.
The Force Awakens, I kinda had no idea what
the end result is.
It was all new, and I'd never worked on anything
that size or scale before."
Fortunately, when it came time to return to
Kylo Ren for the The Last Jedi, he felt comfortable
enough with the character — and the world
— that he was able to unwind a little.
Driver explained:
"The second time I just knew more, so whenever
you kind of know more, for me, I relax a little
bit."
Let's be honest — Kylo Ren has done some
pretty nasty things in his time.
There's killing his dad for one, of course,
but his allegiance with the evil Snoke and
his desire for galactic domination aren't
exactly endearing, either.
You'd think there could be little doubt that
the guy is a real villain.
Heck, he's even got the red lightsaber to
prove it.
But Driver disagrees.
He said that, while preparing to play the
role, he looked for Kylo's human side — and
tried to figure out why he behaves the way
he does.
"Through J.J., kind of hearing what he had
to say about him, tried to hopefully make
him as human as possible."
In an interview with Empire magazine, Driver
explained that part of the reason for his
character's questionable morals is that he's
a fanatic.
He said:
"When they think of their actions as morally
justified, it makes them dangerous and unpredictable.
[...] I never thought of the character as
an evil person."
Driver also lays some of the blame on Kylo's
parents, Han Solo and Leia Organa, and their
obsession with the Rebellion's cause — a
cause Ben Solo didn't necessarily connect
with.
Driver told Entertainment Weekly:
"Looking around and not seeing yourself and
not identifying with what's around you, I
think, affects how we behave."
Of course, it helps that Driver considers
himself closer to the Dark Side than the Light.
As he once joked:
"I live in the Dark Side.
Constantly reminding ourselves that we're
all going to die soon."
For an actor as thoughtful and serious as
Adam Driver, playing a character as angry
and impulsive as Kylo Ren meant tuning into
a certain mindset.
In the past, Driver has said that he views
Kylo Ren as being young, impetuous, and driven
by convictions that, despite being strong,
aren't entirely rational.
According to Driver, that aspect of his character
was really brought to life for The Last Jedi.
"Something about the youthfulness of him was
not lost in Rian's writing."
When first getting to grips with Kylo's character,
Driver realized the character was at that
point of early adulthood where he had to decide
who he wanted to be — and figure out his
place in the world.
So when playing him, Driver looked for something
beyond his own measured demeanor, and tried
to draw out Kylo's less mature and more impulsive
attitude.
And when it came to accessing the anger he
needed for Kylo's explosive bursts, one thing
seems to have worked in particular.
"I just think about taxes and traffic and
I'm there."
Even the best theater school in the world
can't prepare you for every acting challenge,
and Driver struggled with one major aspect
of life in the Star Wars universe: the greenscreen.
The actor told Seth Meyers that it can be
pretty difficult to get into character as
a fearsome villain when you're stuck in front
of a greenscreen on an empty backlot.
"You're standing in front the screen and they’re
like, ‘Trust us, your lightsaber is working’
or ‘There’s space behind you, it looks
really cool.’"
One thing that helped Driver better connect
to Kylo's world was actually watching the
final product.
Driver has said that normally he doesn't watch
the movies he's in, as it makes him feel too
self-conscious — and can interfere with
his ability to embody his character in the
moment.
However, he made an exception for Star Wars,
because he wanted to see what Kylo was experiencing
while Driver was acting against those greenscreens.
He told Esquire:
"Part of the impulse in wanting to see it
is because there is so much visual s--t going
on that I didn't know what was happening."
Driver added that seeing The Force Awakens
helped him understand the world of Star Wars
and reassured him that he was on the right
track — so much so, in fact, that he almost
decided he didn't need to watch The Last Jedi.
The first item on any Dark Sider's checklist
is a good old-fashioned scary mask — even
if it's meant more for intimidating people
than it is for, say, life support.
And while Kylo Ren's mask might help him tap
into his villainous side, Driver himself found
that the headgear was more of a hindrance
than a help when it came to playing the role.
He even described the costume as the hardest
part of returning to the character for The
Last Jedi, saying that working with the mask
is especially challenging because it badly
limits his vision.
"It was terrible, yeah.
To this day, I still don’t know who’s
in the movie because I haven’t seen anybody."
Despite this, Driver also felt that the mask
helped him understand and convey his character's
internal conflict.
For The Force Awakens, the costume department
carefully decided which characters wore masks,
because they didn't want the looks to feel
derivative of the original movies.
Driver said that Kylo's reason for wearing
one is that he's trying to hide his insecurities
about living up to Darth Vader.
He told GQ:
"The person Kylo's pretending to be on the
outside is not who he is.
He's a vulnerable kid who doesn't know where
to put his energy, but when he puts his mask
on, suddenly, he's playing a role."
In order to make Kylo Ren work as a character,
Driver had to find a voice that successfully
conveyed his rage — but didn't come across
as silly at the same time.
So he worked with the sound team to come up
with the robotic voice that would come from
under the mask.
As sound editor Matthew Wood explains:
"I actually came up with a process to allow
Adam Driver to be very method about it, and
hear what his mask was sounding like while
he was performing.
We'd bring him into the studio [...] and he
could get right up on the microphone and get
really creepy about his process and hear it."
But it wasn't just Driver and Wood who had
to be happy with Kylo's voice.
Wood said:
"J.J. [Abrams] [...] really wanted people
to feel it.
He wanted that organic process, and he wanted
Kylo Ren's mask to portray that sort of intimidation."
However, once on set, Abrams apparently changed
his mind about the voice they'd worked on.
During one interview, Driver's co-star Oscar
Isaac recalled that the first scene both actors
shot together was a torture scene.
But things didn't go entirely to plan.
"We did the first take and then J.J. came
up and was was like, ‘Yeah, maybe try something
different.’
And you’re like, ‘What?'"
Fortunately, after that false start, Driver
was able to land on the right voice — and
make Kylo as menacing as he needed to be.
As a 6-foot-3 former Marine, Driver was no
stranger to the physicality required of a
Force-wielding warrior, but he still had to
hit the gym to prepare for the role.
And he made some friends doing so, too.
Shane Finn, who owned a gym in Kerry, Ireland,
met the actor as he prepared for shooting
on The Last Jedi.
Finn described Driver as one of the nicest
guys who had ever trained at the gym, and
said that the actor made a particular effort
to thank the staff for their help during his
training.
Driver's hard work paid off too, inspiring
The Last Jedi director Rian Johnson to introduce
the shirtless scene that has since passed
into Star Wars legend.
Speaking with W magazine, John said:
"He knew he looked good.
Adam looks so damn good because he'd been
training hardcore for the past six months
for those fight scenes.
I'm like, 'Eh.
He looks so good.
We should put him up there.'"
Driver's shirtless scene lived on even after
the movie left cinemas, thanks to a viral
sensation that came to be known as the Kylo
Ren Challenge.
Fans, internet lurkers and even John Mayer
posted photos of themselves shirtless, wearing
the same kind of eyebrow-raising, high-waisted
pants that Driver that wore for the scene.
By far the best part about being in Star Wars
is getting to play around with lightsabers.
Just ask Ewan McGregor.
"To begin with, it was quite difficult NOT
to make the sound."
“Yeah
[sick lightsaber movement noise]
“And also, when it goes away, ‘cause it
makes that nice…”
[sick lightsaber powering down noise]
“... noise.”
Kylo Ren's own red lightsaber, with its unique
plasma crossguard, has already become one
of the saga's most iconic weapons.
And Driver said that this generation of Star
Wars actors have had the privilege of working
with the best lightsabers yet.
He told The Telegraph:
"This is the first time that we're actually
fighting with the whole lightsaber too.
Before it was just the hilt with [something]
like an antenna or a green stick, but this
was state of the art — it actually sends
off light."
Driver's commitment to lightsaber training
earned his co-stars' respect, too.
"I was watching Adam and he gives it so full-out
every single time."
But Driver himself admits that throwing himself
into his fight training was a no-brainer.
"It's just rigorous in a great way and these
stunt guys are very disciplined, so you can’t
half-ass it."
Luckily for the cast, mastering the moves
for The Force Awakens made preparing for The
Last Jedi just a little easier.
Speaking with ScreenSlam, Driver said:
"Because we started [Last Jedi] almost a month
after we finished The Force Awakens, that
kind of vocabulary was still in our bodies,
so it made things easier, a little bit faster.
But the rigor of doing it was maybe more intense
for this one."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.